How is everyone doing today?
[CHEERING]
You know why there's
a lot of excitement,
and I saw the silent
praise, because I
know what this means, recently,
and I'm doing more and more.
You guys are excited, because
we are celebrating something
on Friday.
We are celebrating knowledge,
we are celebrating chemistry,
and we are celebrating
how much we've
learned in the last month.
It's called exam three.
Woo.
It's a midterm.
Thank you for that.
What I thought we'd
do today instead of--
again, I mentioned
this on Monday.
You guys just had
Thanksgiving, you're back,
and now we've got a test.
And I know you've got a
lot of other stuff going on
too at this time.
So instead of throwing
something in that we're not
going to test you on, what
I wanted to do with today
was just to kind of feel our
oneness with the concepts.
All right?
And so I want to go
over the concepts that
are going to be potentially
on the exam on Friday,
and I'll talk about
those concepts,
and we'll do a
couple of problems
here and there as we go.
OK, so those are the metrics,
the specs, for exam three.
But on Monday, I finished
with two minutes left,
and I said, hey,
there's one more
kind of acid-base definition.
You won't be tested on it,
but it's the most general,
and I've got to
give Lewis his due.
So I just wanted to
just show you like that.
You won't be tested on
Lewis acids and bases,
but I did throw this
in there, and so
I want to just, for one or two
more minutes, talk about this.
Right?
These are the things you
are responsible for knowing.
So an Arrhenius acid-base--
OH, H plus.
Bronsted-Lowry.
It's proton transfer.
And then there's
Lewis, who broasted
these guys, because
he said, uh-uh,
and this is the most general way
to think about acids and bases.
It is the most general.
It is quite powerful, because
you go back to say this one,
and so if this is a--
what if we mix this with this?
So here we have H.
Now, remember, Lewis had all
the dots all over the place.
He loved dots, and so
they're all over the place.
And that's what if you had
this, this is a Lewis acid,
because it is ready to receive.
What is it ready to receive?
No more atoms, only electrons.
It is the most general
way to think about it.
All right?
And this would be a
Lewis base, because it
is ready to give a
pair of electrons
and form a bond together.
And that's what they do,
or that's what they can do.
So a Lewis acid and a Lewis
base is the most general form,
and you really get rid of--
so for Lewis, it's all
about electron transfer,
electron pair transfer, pair
transfer, or bonds if you're--
I'm just going to make it
as general as possible.
If you're going to mix
an acid and a base,
which I'll do in a
second, it's a pair.
Electron transfer is
what it's all about,
and what happens here?
Well, you don't have
any chemical identity,
no more chemical identity.
So it's full.
You don't need the
hydrogens anymore.
You don't need the OH's.
It's totally general.
And this really opens
it up, because now you
can look at gases, liquid,
solids, all forms of matter,
all elements in the table, and
you can think about them as
whether they're going
to have an acid-like
or a base-like character in
terms of electron transfer.
So here's the general-- if you
had a Lewis acid and a Lewis
base, and you mix them together.
Then, you can see that
if you got an electron
pair that could then go--
that one of them wants it,
and the other can give it,
and they can form
a bond, then that
would be how you think about
mixing a Lewis acid and a Lewis
base.
And again, this
won't be on the exam,
but I just had to
give Lewis his due.
OK, Lewis acids and bases
are all about the electrons.
And then the other thing I
didn't get to do on Monday
was my Why This Matters,
and so I want to do that.
Now hair is very much affected
by the softness of water.
But instead of me showing
you lots of pictures of hair
that I found randomly on the
internet, googling soft water,
hard water, different
forms of water, hair,
I'm showing you pipes, because
that's much more actually
relevant in terms of like, for
example, whether you can get
water into your house at all.
All right?
And this is a real problem.
If you have hard
water what it means
is you've got
minerals in the water.
Right?
Things like magnesium and
calcium ions are in the water.
And what happens is, if you run
that through pipes, they tend
to react and form and deposit.
And you get these deposits
of very, very hard mineral
deposits around the edges that
eventually look like this.
That's not a good thing.
And so you need to soften the
water, and that's something
you may have heard of.
But now you really know how
to think about it, because you
can think about it in
terms of all of the things
that you've learned.
And just as an example,
if one of those minerals
that's a problem is calcium--
oh, it is, right?
Magnesium is another one
that can cause this in pipes.
You've got to somehow
take it out of the water
or at least make it into a form
that makes it like insoluble,
so it'll just flow, and
it won't have a chance
to come around and deposit on
the edge there of the pipe.
And so what do you do?
Well, you add, for example--
oh, we've done this before.
Right?
What if I add soda,
something called soda ash?
Oh, we know what that is.
That's Na2CO3, and that
will give me some ions.
It'll give me some
Na pluses, and it'll
give me some CO3 2 minuses,
and those are in aqueous.
Now, this is all
part of the stuff
that we've been talking about.
You're dissociating this
to get ions in solution,
but why do I want these ions?
That's a water softener.
Why?
Because now you can see it.
Right?
Because this one
here, this one here
is going to remove the calcium.
So if I've got these
calcium, these minerals,
in the water making it hard
water which leads to that
and wreaks havoc on
your hair, then you
get a little of this
in there, and you're
going to react with the calcium.
Why?
It's because of
what we already saw.
If I have this--
this is something we've already
looked at-- if I have calcium 2
plus, and I have some
bicarbonate in there,
CO3 minus, then we know that
I can get precipitates, Ca--
this is just what we looked
at in the goody bag, right--
plus CO2 plus H2O.
That's the same kind of reaction
that we looked at already.
We have calcium carbonate,
calcium carbonate.
Why?
Well, because this is
going to give me these.
This is a source for those
which then eats up some calcium.
And you think, well, now this
can take the calcium ions out,
so that it runs through.
That's what you want to do here.
That's how you soften water.
Well, you can add lime which
gives me a source of OH minus,
and that takes
out the magnesium.
And these are ways to change
the chemistry of water,
so that you don't have
as many ions, mineral,
these calcium and magnesium
ions floating around that cause
problems.
So that was my Why This
Matters, and now we
turn to what I started
with which is exam three.
Oh, look at that.
I look at that, and
that's just happiness.
Look at all those topics--
X-rays XRD, defects, glasses,
reaction rates, solubility,
aqueous solutions, acids/bases.
It's all there.
It's all there, and it's all
there in you, and if not,
you've got two days.
So please, make it be there.
Let's go through this.
I'm going to go through
this topic right there.
So I'm going to tell
you the concepts that I
want to make sure you know.
OK, so here's the first one.
So it's X-rays, and XRD.
So what do I want you to know?
Well, for example,
I want you to know
about how you have
characteristic, characteristic,
characteristic X-rays,
and remember this?
This comes from
those transitions.
Right?
So you get like the K and the
L and the M. We say et cetera.
We never really did
et cetera, but we've
got a lot of K and L lines
we looked at, alpha, beta,
but there's also the continuous.
Right?
So this was in--
if you want-- this would be in
the topic of X-ray generation,
and there's that Bremsstrahlung
word that means breaking.
Right?
So if you just want
to look at this,
you might have a
curve that looks--
OK, so we had things like this.
Right?
Oh, I'm going to try to
make it not look too bad,
and there's another
one, and so on.
And remember, so this would
be like intensity, intensity,
and this would be like maybe a
lambda going that way or maybe
energy going that
way or frequency.
Right?
Those would be like the x-axis,
and these are those lines.
Those are the lines, and they
come from the transitions
that you get from like
the K level to the L level
to the M level.
Right?
Remember, if you get the energy
high enough of an incident
electron onto a
target, metal, then you
can knock out electrons
from that 1s shell.
And then something
cascades down,
and that emits these lines here.
So that'd be like K alpha,
K alpha, K beta, et cetera.
But then, you also,
even at lower energies,
even if you don't
have enough energy
to knock out a 1s
electron, you still
can slow an electron down as
it goes through a metal atom.
And that's where you get
this continuous spectrum
and that limit of how much of
that type of X-ray you get.
And it just depends
on the incident,
on the voltage, on the
maximum incident electron
you fire at it.
So that's those
first two topics.
OK?
Well, oh, we also did
X-ray diffraction.
Oh, that's fun, diffraction.
OK, and this involves
understanding Bragg,
the Bragg condition, and
also selection rules.
So let's just take a look at
an example of the diffraction
and selection rules.
OK?
So what would I want?
So these are like
the kind of concepts
that I want you to know about.
How might it play out?
So like, OK, so here's like
an example of a spectrum.
Now, that's an X-ray spectrum
for MgFeO4, magnesium ferrite,
and it's a kind of steel.
And you put it in, you
make a powder of it,
and and you throw
some X-rays on it.
Oh no, you throw just
one type of X-ray on it.
All right?
So for these X-ray
spectra, what happened?
I threw some K alpha on it,
I showed right there, you
got to say what you got.
All right?
You've got to know at
least the source of X-rays
has this wavelength.
Good.
And if I have that
spectrum, and say,
what's the lattice constant?
What's the structure?
I can get that.
How would I get that?
So I would take this
spectrum, and notice something
is very much pointed out to
me, a peak and a number, 35.5.
Right?
That's the 2 theta
value for the 311 peak.
Well, I think I'll
take that as a hint.
Maybe I should think about that
number, and OK, so let's see.
From Bragg, so from
Bragg, you know
that you got n lambda
equals 2d sine theta,
and remember that had to do with
constructive and destructive
interference of waves, the
waves being the X-rays.
And then we said, well, n is 1
in our class, so that's just 1
in 3,091.
It doesn't have to be.
You could have interference
off of two planes down,
three planes down,
but in this class,
we're just doing the two
planes next to each other.
So n is 1.
OK?
Now, I'll take that angle, and
I'll round it to 18 degrees.
So I'm going to say for theta
equals 18 degrees, then--
oh, wait, why is it 18?
Because that's 2 theta.
Right?
Because remember, we
take spectra in 2 theta,
but the theta in
Bragg is 1 theta.
OK, that wasn't too hard.
But now, I've got, let's see,
sine theta is around 0.3,
and oh, I got lambda.
Lambda equals 1.54 nanometers,
and so I can actually
plug in now.
I didn't even need the peak.
I'm just plugging in the Bragg
condition, and I've got d.
d equals 2.52
Angstroms, so I'm done.
No.
No, I'm not done, because
the question says,
what's the lattice constant?
What's the lattice constant?
This d, I didn't say--
I did something very bad--
I didn't say what d--
d is in hkl.
That's what an XRD does.
XRD, that's a different
than diffraction, but the d,
in Bragg, is the distance
between the mirror planes
that are scattering.
All right?
And so that's some
cuts in the crystal.
That's some hkl, and
we know from that era
that there is an equation
for cubic crystals
that gives us hkl
which is a divided
by the square root of h squared
plus k squared plus l squared.
And that is the lattice
constant of the crystal,
and that would be the
distance between any planes,
any set of planes,
in the crystal,
and that's what we need.
Now, I can use that,
combine it with the d,
and I can get that the lattice
constant is 8.38 Angstroms.
Good.
But the second question is--
you don't even need to do
any math to answer that--
what is the lattice structure?
Here, we simply go to
our selection rules,
and we know from before if
they're all even or all odd--
so here we have, let's
see, all these peaks--
220, 311, 400.
You can see, they're
always all even,
or they're always all odd.
From our selection rules,
what kind of crystal is that?
It's got to be FCC.
All right?
So that's the answer
to that question,
just from looking at
the peaks that you get
and matching them with the
selection rules that you know,
that we've already talked about.
You could also, if you
didn't have the planes--
so this is an example, where
you're given all these planes.
You're given all these hkls,
but what if instead it's
like the one we had in class?
We went through this in class.
Here, I'm not given the planes.
I'm given instead
just two theta values.
Well now, you've got to go
and use the procedure of XRD,
and I'm not going
to do that again.
We've already done
that pretty thoroughly,
but that's what you
would have to do here,
where you create your columns.
Remember the columns?
All right?
So you would simply make your
columns, you make your sign,
your thetas, your 2 theta
theta sine squared thetas.
And then you normalize,
you take the lowest one,
and you normalize to 1.
Clear fractions, and then
find the hkl combinations,
and that's how you would
go from this to getting,
for example, the planes.
So those are some
examples of things
I want you to be able to
do with X-rays and XRD.
Let's move on.
Let's go to the next topic.
Let's do defects.
How about this, defects,
because as we said,
it's just like life,
crystals, defects
are what make them interesting.
It's the same.
Everything, it's
all about defects,
imperfections, those are
the interesting and exciting
things, so we've got to know
about them in chemistry,
of course.
So we've talked about a bunch
of different kinds of defects.
The first one that
we talked about
were vacancies, vacancies, and
these could be interstitial.
These fall into the category of
point defects, point defects,
right?
You could also have
interstitial point defects,
interstitial or substitutional.
Those are the different
kinds of defects we've
talked about for point defects.
Also, by the way, if it's an
ionic point defect, ionic point
defect, you need
to make sure you
have charge neutrality, charge
neutrality, plus two types.
There's Frenkel, and
there's Schottky.
You can think about
Schottky, you remove,
but you've got to remove them
in a way that's charge-balanced.
Right?
So in Schottky, you remove.
In an ionic crystal,
you've got to keep charge.
That's a new thing you've
got to keep track of.
And so if we had--
I'll go to this picture.
Well, you should
know this picture.
This is an important picture.
We showed it a lot--
vacancy, interstitial,
self-interstitial,
substitutional.
And then if it's ionic,
now all of a sudden,
you've got charges in
there, and so you've just
got to make sure
things remain neutral.
Right?
In Schottky, you would remove
atoms to balance the charge,
and in Frenkel,
you move an atom.
Schottky remove, Frenkel move.
That just occurred to me,
that that's the same word
with just re in front of it.
That's exciting.
Well, so if I were to ask
you, for example, if I were to
ask you this.
You diffuse chromium into
one side of the ionic crystal
alumina to make it red
and titanium on the other.
Would you expect oxygen
vacancies, aluminum vacancies,
or no vacancies in each case?
Just follow the charge,
follow the charge.
So for example, if
I had alumina, O3.
Well, if I were
Lewis, if I were Lewis
I would see this as 2Al3 plus.
Right?
This is how he saw ionic bonds.
Ah, I want to make
sure this is clear.
I'm going to start over.
So I would have 2Al3 plus, and
then I would have a 3O2 minus.
Remember, O likes to
be 2 minus, and so
if I were to introduce
something like Cr2O3,
well, this is 2Cr3 plus, so this
is 2Cr3 plus, and 3O2 minus.
So if I substitute
aluminum with chromium,
then I'm charge-balanced.
Right?
I'm OK.
But if I substitute titanium,
TiO2 is Ti4 plus and 2O2 minus,
you know this just
from the formula.
Because if oxygen is 2 minus,
this thing's got to be neutral,
and so that's Ti4 plus.
But now, if I put a Ti
in there, and I get one
in for an aluminum, I've
knocked the charge by 1.
Right?
So this gives us
an extra charge,
and that means you've
got to create vacancies,
create aluminum vacancies.
It's the only way to do it.
So for every three titanium
atoms that I put in,
I've got to take an
aluminum one out.
Right?
Otherwise, I'm not going
to have charge balance,
not going to have
charge balance.
Right?
So that would be an example of
playing with an ionic crystal,
but remember, we also
had stress-strain curves.
Because when we talked
about line defects,
we talked about how that's a way
for metals and other materials
to undergo deformation.
And then we said,
well, how are we
going to conceptualize
these things happening,
and we did it with the
stress-strain curve
and the mechanical
response of materials.
So we learned about
stress-strain curves
and fracture points,
fracture and plastic
versus elastic regimes.
OK, I'll give an
example in a sec.
OK?
And finally, the last
thing we did with defects
is we talked about
their activation.
And so we know if something
is thermally activated,
as are point defects, vacancies
are thermally activated,
so are other types
of point defects.
And we said that we need
an Arrhenius relationship,
and that requires
knowledge of an activation
energy for the defect to form.
So that was another
really important concept
that we covered.
Right?
So for example, here is like
a defect formation energy
question.
So let me go over here, stay
with this side, where I've got
some defects.
So one thing I
want to make clear,
the fraction of vacancies.
We talked about this.
We talked about an
Arrhenius behavior,
Arrhenius-like behavior, and
the fraction of vacancies
was the number of vacancies over
the number of possible sites.
That makes a lot of sense.
Now, if it's
Arrhenius, then this
is some constant times e to the
minus activation energy divided
by KBT, where we use
the Boltzmann constant
if it's per atom.
Right?
So per vacancy, that activation
energy would be per vacancy.
But when I first introduced
this, I simply let a be 1,
but a is a constant.
This is a constant,
and it can be whatever.
It's a constant.
It's called the
anthropic factor,
and it's a constant related
to as you would have
in any Arrhenius-like behavior.
Right?
Remember how it's like
a frequency factor,
this is related to all
sorts of complexities
that we don't need to know about
related to how vacancies form.
It's a constant that's in
there, and I let it be 1,
but I want to make sure
we put it in explicitly.
This n is the number
of possible sites.
Right?
So maybe it's the number of
lattice sites in the crystal,
number of possible sites.
But you might get
this could be related
to, for example, or to or
from, things like the grams
that you have of something
or maybe the volume
or the moles, et cetera.
Right?
So these are the kinds
of problems we've done.
That gives you a sense of
how many sites did you have.
Right?
It could be per
centimeter cubed.
It could be per moles.
You go back and forth.
How much stuff do I have?
It's that kind of
back and forth.
If I had a problem like this,
then I know I can set it up,
because I've got
two temperatures.
You see the key here,
the concentration of 10
to the cubed per
centimeter cubed,
so don't let that throw you off.
It's simply two equations,
where a bunch of stuff cancels.
Right?
So the fraction
of vacancies, fv1,
would be 10 to the
3rd divided by fv2,
and that's going to be 10 to
the 3rd over 10 to the 16th,
because the number
of stuff cancels.
Right?
I didn't change that.
But this pre-factor cancels too.
You can put it there, A times
e to the minus ea divided by KB
times 300 Kelvin--
remember, so it was Kelvin--
divided by A times to the
minus ea divided by KB times
the other temperature,
900 Kelvin.
Right?
And so those cancel,
the stuff related to n
cancels, and I can just take
the number of vacancies.
Right?
So that's what's nice about
having something like this.
You have two temperatures
and a whole bunch of stuff
can cancel, and you can figure
out then the activation energy
which doesn't change.
The activation energy is simply
the energy that you need,
so you can now solve for ea,
and I think you get something
like 2.3 electron volts.
Remember that you could
also have plotted it.
You'd know that
in this equation,
in the Arrhenius relationship,
if you take the log,
then you have the minus
1 over T relationship.
So remember that?
So if you take the
T versus the log,
then you're going to get that.
Right?
We like plots, when we
think about Arrhenius,
because it makes it easier.
We can make it linear,
where the slope of this
is minus ea, the slope, minus
ea over KB, in this case.
Right?
So we talked about these
are all kinds of things
that we talked about.
And finally, getting
to this stress-strain,
what if we looked at this?
This is the stress-strain,
so now we're here.
We just did this.
We talked about that.
We talked about this,
so stress-strain.
So if you were to be given
plots like this, you should know
which one is most
brittle, which one
is the stiffest, the
most resistant to
changing elastically, and
which one is the most ductile?
You can see that
the stiffest one
is going to be the one
that's the most resistant to
elastic deformation.
That's that linear
part, that first part.
So there, it's
going to be material
A. It's going to be A, because
it's got the highest slope.
Right?
OK.
How about the most brittle?
Well, that's the one
that's going to break.
So it sort of looks like--
without deforming, without being
able to undergo defamation,
that's brittleness.
It's going to crack
before doing anything.
So that's B, right?
That's B.
And then the most ductile will
be the one that has the most
plastic deformation, because
that's what ductility is,
so that's going to be C. OK?
So remember
stress-strain curves.
You've got this elastic
part here, that's linear,
and then if it's a material--
not all materials have
plastic defamation.
Some are going to
break before they
start deforming plastically, but
if it can deform plastically,
then it's going to
have that yield point.
Right?
The yield stress, where then
it starts becoming non-linear,
and then finally, it
fractures somewhere else.
OK?
So those are
stress-strain curves.
OK, let's move on.
Now, oh, with the next topic--
oh boy, I'm going to
run out of real estate--
we've got glasses, and here,
the most important thing
to know about is the curve.
That's how it all started.
Right?
I'm calling it The Curve.
Let's go all caps,
because it's The Curve,
and what I mean by The
Curve is the volume
per mole versus temperature.
We also talked about the
effects of cooling rate,
and we also talked about
the effects of modifiers,
and in particular how the
modifier changes the viscosity
because it cuts the pasta.
OK, so but the framing of these
concepts was in The Curve,
and that's this one.
Oh, I have a picture of it.
There it is.
OK, they did specific--
we do volume per mole
is how we're looking at it in
this class, so volume per mole
versus temperature.
Now remember, if it's a
crystal, where am I going to go?
Let's go here.
If it's a crystal, then you've
got one melting point that
only depends on the material.
It only depends on the material,
so that melting point is Tm,
and it's going to have a
big volume change as it goes
from liquid to crystal solid.
OK?
And so for example, I'm just
basically replotting it,
but you would have something
like this and something
like this and
something like this,
and that's your melting point.
This would be the liquid,
and this would be the solid,
and you know that, if it's
going to undergo this big volume
change.
Then, it's the melting
point and it's a crystal.
But then we say, well,
but if it can't find--
by crystal I mean in opposition
to glass, which we know
doesn't just mean your windows.
It means any amorphous material,
meaning it's not crystalline.
It didn't find the
lattice structure.
Remember those three
reasons, the musical chairs?
Whatever you're trying
to crystallize, atoms
or molecules, they weren't able
to find all the lattice sites,
not even withstanding
some defects here.
They simply couldn't do
it, and so it's amorphous,
and it's a glass.
And in that case,
what happens is it
super cools and then
becomes a solid at something
called the glass
transition temperature.
Which unlike the crystal
can have different values,
and those values can depend on
things like the cooling rate.
So if I cool it slower,
if I cool it slower--
remember this is faster,
faster, slower, and please,
do not confuse time
with this axis.
This is just temperature.
So we can use the same--
this is volume per mole-- we can
use the same The Plot to think
about modifiers as well.
Because it's not-- this is
just one plot, one curve
and another.
This happened to
be cooled slower,
so it was able to
super cool more,
before it locked
in the disorder,
and the other one's faster.
You could also imagine
if you cut the pasta,
you change the viscosity.
And so now you're
changing something else
about the glass using
chemistry, and you're
allowing it to find those
lattice sites more easily.
You're allowing it to try
to become crystalline,
to try to close pack
just a little bit more.
So you can also get this,
by cutting the pasta you
can get these kinds of changes.
So those are the things we
talked about with glass.
Now, next, we talked
about reactions.
OK.
What do we need to know about
reactions, reaction rates?
So we want to know the order
of some general reaction,
like aA plus bB--
remember this--
goes to cC plus dD.
And we want to know
the rate from--
basically, it's the
mass conservation,
so from the coefficients.
OK, so that would
be, for example,
like minus 1 over a, d(A), dt--
that's a rate-- equals minus
1 over b d(B), dt, et cetera.
Now, those come from
the coefficients,
but the rate law does not,
the rate law does not.
So these are simply
instantaneous rates,
but now I say, no, I
want a rate law that
gives me the dependence on these
concentrations at any time.
So the rate law would
be, for example,
like rate equals k times
A to the m, B to the n.
Now, here's the thing.
These come from experiments.
Very important
distinction, right?
Those come from
experiments, and so you
could get the rate with
respect to A which would be--
I'm sorry.
The order with respect
to A would be m,
the order with respect
to B would be n,
and the overall
order of the reaction
is m plus n, the overall order.
And then, we had one more
item here of conceptually
what I want you to know about,
which is that the rate also
depends on temperature.
Sorry, the rate
constant, rate constant
depends on temperature.
So if I were to now
say, well, OK, I
want to know something about
the order of a reaction,
you might get a table like
this, and we did this in class.
You might get a
table just like this.
Here's a reaction.
It's W and X and Y,
and it goes to Z.
Don't let the fact that you have
three reactants throw you off.
You've got a certain
number of reactants,
they've got their coefficients,
and they go to some product.
And now, you're given
experimental data, so
from this data, you
can get the order
of the reaction with respect
to each one of these.
Right?
And that would then give you,
of course, the overall order.
So let's see.
If we were to look at that
data, then what would we get?
So what you want to do in
these kinds of situations is,
first of all, don't panic.
By the way, on an exam,
in general, don't panic,
and if you have a question,
you can ask a question,
but also show us what you know.
We will give you-- as you
I hope have seen already--
we will give you as much
credit as we can for sharing
what you know.
You don't have to get everything
right to get a lot of points.
Please share your knowledge.
So in this case, what
would the knowledge be?
Well, it would be that
I want to compare stuff,
like trial 1 and 2.
And if I do that, you see,
OK, trial 1, trial 2, then two
of them stay constant,
but W doubles.
OK?
So comparing 1 versus 2, you
got W goes to 2 two times,
but the rate is
same, so you know
the order is 0 with respect to
W. But if I compare 1 versus 3,
then you know that,
let's see, x goes to 3x
and the rate goes to 3x,
and so the order is 1.
And then finally, for Y--
I will just jump to it--
the order is 2, and you can
do that just by find one
where only Y changes.
You don't have to
necessarily find one
where just one changes.
Right?
Because if you knew
one is first order--
if you knew one, and then you
had another one, and they both
changed.
But maybe the rate
didn't change,
then you know they must have
both the same order, if they
change in opposite ways.
Right?
So you can get into
this in different ways,
just looking at these
changes from one to another
and thinking about
what must happen
in terms of the
rate law, in terms
of what you wrote out here.
But you could also ask
questions like with reactions,
OK, this is first order.
What's the dependence
of the concentration
over time as a function
of the rate constant?
Well, that just goes back to our
understanding of the integrated
rate equation.
Right?
And so let's see, oh
boy, now I need to find--
I'm going to go--
I hate to do this, XRD.
I hate to do this, but
sometimes being first carries
a consequence.
OK.
So in this case--
first of all, by the
way, you look at reaction
like that, you're like, well
OK, from the coefficients
and the mass balance stuff, you
know that the change in oxygen,
for example, with
time, the instantaneous
rate would equal minus the
change in MO2 with time.
Well, that's not what
the question asked.
The question says
it's first order.
So that's enough, because
this means that if I integrate
the rate law then-- first of
all, if it's first order--
then d of MO2 with
respect to time
must equal some constant
times the concentration of MO2
to the 1, first order.
And so now, if I
integrate this, I
take this concentration over
here, I put the dt over there.
You integrate it.
You've got all the
integrated rate laws.
We've gone through this already.
You know that you
get that the log--
oh, we do logs--
are this MO2 equals the log
of some starting concentration
minus Kt.
OK?
Why do we do that?
Because we like plotting
things, linear things.
We love linear.
So remember, we did this.
We went from these
integrated rate
laws to plots and
back and forth,
and so that's also
very important.
OK.
Now finally, so the
last couple of things.
And I'm purposely giving these
last ones a little less time,
because they're the ones that
we've seen very recently,
and these are the
ones that we haven't
seen for almost a month.
Right?
Yeah, but you still gotta
know about solubility,
and so for solubility,
remember what we did is we did
equilibrium and Le Chatelier,
and we did the equilibrium
constants, the K's.
Like for example, Ksp is
the solubility product,
solubility product constant.
Right?
And then we also did
ice tables, and then we
talked about the common ion.
And so as an example,
if I were to tell you,
well, OK, I'm going
to take BaCl2.
I might have done this
one in class already.
If I add BaCl2 to a
saturated solution of BaSO4,
why does it cause precipitation?
Answer-- because
of the common ion
effect, but you could
write these out.
So you write out your
saturated solution,
so you write out
your BaSO4, and you
see that BaSO4 solid will
go to Ba2 plus in solution
plus SO4 2 minus in solution.
And so the common
ion effect tells you
that if I now add something else
that has something in common
with one of these, that
gives me an ion in common,
then because of Le
Chatelier, you're
going to drive the
reaction the other way.
That precipitates, because
it forms a solid BaSO4.
So I've just done that.
Right?
I've given you BaCl2 which
gives you a source of Ba2 plus,
and how do you figure
out if you were
given amounts what happens,
what the new equilibrium is?
You use ICE.
Right?
You use the ICE tables.
OK.
And then finally, we talked
about acids and bases.
Oh, I really hate to erase
defects, but here we go.
Defects are gone.
Arrhenius, I'm so sorry.
That was painful.
And the last topic here
is acids and bases,
and this is the most recent
one, and so what do we have?
Well, got the acid equilibrium
constant, the base.
We did water.
We did pH.
Oh, we did p anything.
Right?
p equals negative log
of the thing, pKa, pKb.
OK, and then we did, like
for example, the definitions,
so Arrhenius versus
Bronsted-Lowry definitions.
And so for example, if you're
given a solution-- this is one,
just a simple
example of an acid--
and it's HOCN, and
you're given the acid.
And you know the pH,
so you're given that.
Then the pH from that
information you can get that
the concentration of H plus--
which is also a H3O plus--
is 1.7 times 10 to the
minus 3 moles per liter.
That's from the pH,
and if you have that,
then you can go to the
Ka definition, which
is H plus concentration OCN
minus divided by the acid HOCN
concentration, and
you've got it all.
Because if you're right the
equilibrium equation, which
is what Ka describes, the
equilibrium of this acid
dissociating into
ions, dissociating
into H plus and OCN minus,
and so you can get Ka.
OK.
So what I hope is that
this got us in the mood,
that this got us all kind of
on the right page with respect
to these topics.
You've got two days.